we do have limited time but I'd like to
try to squeeze one more caller in let's
try the 267 area code caller from 267
we've got about a minute tell me what's
on your mind today
oh okay Connor from Penn State from last
week again but I was just gonna ask you
I don't know if you can answer this in a
minute but he'll your ideal policy to
address immigrate new immigration issue
in the country we're with Mexico who
could barely address it in 30 minutes
never mind one minute but we've got a
long-form video on this it's called the
truth about undocumented immigration we
talk about what wouldn't work we talk
about sensible reforms it's a very good
piece the very very good piece Connor
all right and I only have a short time I
just want to say if another 216 number
calls that's a fraud from he's my
roommate named also Connor he's gonna
try to impersonate me do not let that
guy get any time yeah I heard about I
was trying to keep that sheltered from
this because I thought that it would
really upset him we don't want the good
name of Connor to be soiled by his
roommate there's a whole Twitter thing
going on we're like I guess both these
guys named Connor are roommates and
they're both calling in and like if I
recall correctly I was even confused by
their twitter presences where I thought
it was one person for a while it's a
whole weird thing but what I can assure
you as we are never going back to the
267 area code we've learned our lesson
now I'm kidding we don't have any
blacklisted area codes but we do need
caller ID on our system there's a few
reasons why and maybe I'll tell you on a
different day okay let's go to
commercial break and then we will get
right into our classic interview which
is a doozy today